è il 3 marzo del 2006 Sono le 5 del
mattino squilla il mio telefono
cellulare
all'epoca non era una cosa insolida per
l'incarico per ricoprivo la cosa
insolita era che a chiamarmi fosse
direttamente il capo del Servizio
Centrale operativo che per noi
poliziotti è la massima autorità nel
campo delle indagini mi dice che fai
Dormi Hai sentito cosa è successo a
Parma Ancora stordito gli rispondo No no
sono sveglio so tutto Naturalmente non
era vero lui l'ha capito mi dice bene
prepara la strumentazione viene in
ufficio con la valigia porta chi vuoi
dei tuoi Tanto tra poco ci vediamo in
ufficio
all'epoca era un giovane funzionario Mi
occupavo di intercettazioni e di
indagini elettroniche ed era la prima
volta che un investigatore di quel
calibro mi chiamava direttamente sul mio
telefono cellulare e per questo motivo
ero veramente gasato
dopo due ore ero sull'autostrada per
Parma dove era stato rapito un bambino
un bambino di 18 mesi Tommaso Onofri
quel bimbo che di lì a poco per tutta
l'Italia sarebbe diventato il piccolo
Tommy
da quel giorno a Parma è partita
un'indagine pazzesca avevamo ritmi di
lavoro allucinanti praticamente non
dormivamo mai le tracce che avevamo a
disposizione non erano mai sufficienti
per dirci se la pista che seguivamo era
quella giusta se realmente saremmo
arrivati ai rapitori
Considerate che seguivamo almeno dieci
viste in contemporanea per una che
riuscivamo ad escluderne subentravano
altre due non potevamo trascurare né
nulla avevamo nelle mani la vita di un
bimbo anche le viste assurde come le
visioni dei maghi anche quelle devono
essere tagliate
io avevo parecchi problemi dove
analizzare i tabulati e in base alle
Celle capire se determinati soggetti
erano non erano sulla scena del crimine
ma non ci riuscivo il ritmo delle
indagini era incalzante facevo delle
localizzazioni ci mettevo una settimana
a volte facevano un errore di un
chilometro e questo non andava
assolutamente bene e quando mi giravo e
vedevo gli altri miei colleghi che
lavorano su altri settori avevano gli
stessi problemi
Ci sono voluti 30 lunghissimi giorni per
trovare da restare i rapitori del
piccolo Tommy
che purtroppo era stato ucciso 20 minuti
dopo il sequestro perché piangeva
qualsiasi sforzo Sarebbe comunque stato
inutile
Quel giorno si è concluso il mio
battesimo del fuoco quelle attività che
mi aveva posto faccia a faccia con tutti
i miei limiti e i limiti del mio ufficio
Ed è proprio quel giorno davanti a quel
corpicino che ci siamo detti che così
non poteva andare
non poteva andare che cos'era la polizia
scientifica la polizia scientifica era
un gruppo di tecnici che applicava delle
tecniche delle metodologie nella maggior
parte dei casi alla perfezione senza
errori
Ma le tecniche erano sempre le stesse a
volte erano anche vecchie di 10 anni
quando un investigatore ci formulava una
domanda che usurava dall'ordinario la
risposta quello che noi rispondevamo più
In generale era questo non si può fare
C'era addirittura che rispondeva no
facciamo così perché abbiamo sempre
fatto così
oggi Io sono qui per raccontarvi Come è
cambiata la polizia scientifica e come
abbiamo fatto per cambiarla
appena sono tornato da parla' ma mi sono
messo subito a lavorare su quelli che
erano i miei problemi ho preso un
software che ho utilizzato per la mia
tesi di laurea questo mi permetteva di
georeferenziare alcuni dati e di
effettuare delle analisi statistiche lo
abbiamo unito da uno strumento di misura
e abbiamo realizzato un metodo
infallibile per l'analisi delle Celle
altro che Parma qui in poche ore
otteniamo un dato con la precisione del
metro lo abbiamo applicato in tutte le
indagini successive con un successo
notevole
ma non ci siamo fermati lì abbiamo
continuato a studiare a lavorarci sopra
e alla fine siamo riusciti ad arrivare
ad una rappresentazione tridimensionale
dei tabulati una cosa che neanche ci
speravamo
ma oggi è la polizia scientifica non è
cambiato solo questo oggi è la polizia
scientifica è cambiato tutto
vi ricordate il 7 dicembre del 2011
quando la squadra mobile di Napoli dopo
15 anni di latitanza ha Arrestato
Michele Zagaria il capo dei casalesi è
stato trovato in un bunker sotterraneo e
volete sapere come abbiamo fatto a
trovarlo
anche grazie all'intercettazioni e senza
neanche usare una microspia
noi abbiamo seguito l'evoluzione di
queste microspie dagli anni 90 dove
c'erano quelle analogiche fino al 2000
Con l'avvento del digitale fino ai
giorni d'oggi oggi Oggi non abbiamo
bisogno neanche della microspia di chi
va collocarla Ci basta inserire un
software in un PC in un telefono e
attivare il microfono
e la stessa cosa La potremmo dire per la
cattura di Bernardo Provenzano Il capo
dei capi di Cosa nostra è stato
catturato grazie al sofisticatissime
telecamere che da chilometri di distanza
ci permettevano di monitorare tutti gli
spostamenti dei suoi uomini e anche qui
di questi sistemi Abbiamo seguito
l'evoluzione dagli anni 90 al 2000 fino
ad oggi
vi ricordate il 28 settembre del 1988
viene ucciso in un agguato il
giornalista Mauro Rostagno
dopo 23 anni di indagine gli errori
giudiziari e di depistaggi soltanto nel
2011 è stato riaperto il processo e
questa volta con le ipotesi
dell'omicidio di mafia di un omicidio
commesso per punire un uomo libero che
scriveva ciò che pensava
con la riapertura del processo siamo in
grado di utilizzare le nuove tecniche
che abbiamo messo al punto nel campo
delle indagini merceologiche pensate da
alcuni frammenti di un fanale repertati
sulla scena del crimine siamo riusciti
ad attribuirli alla Fiat Tipo dei Killer
quest'anno fare impensabile Perché
Perché un vetro non vedono una plastica
Era una plastica oggi siamo in grado di
identificare quel vetro e di capirne la
provenienza quel vetro quella plastica
quel tessuto quella Fibra quella vernice
quel metallo
pensate a quel DNA la prova regina che
non solo ci permette di risolvere i
delitti che avvengono oggi ma anche
quelli che sono avvenuti tanti anni fa e
sono rimasti insoluti perché oggi siamo
in grado di leggere quelle tracce che
anni fa non potevano essere lette Grazie
all'amplificazione una tecnica che dà
una singola molecola ci permette di
ottenere migliaia di sequenze di DNA
In poche parole se prima per estrarre il
DNA avevo bisogno di una certa quantità
di sostanza come ad esempio una piazza
di sangue oggi è sufficiente una cellula
una cellula di sfaldamento epiteliale
che la mia pelle rilascia quando tocco
un oggetto
la stessa cosa La potremmo dire per le
impronte digitali sono l'accertamento
storico di polizia scientifica Il più
antico Le usiamo da oltre un secolo ma
soltanto oggi ne sfruttiamo a pieno le
potenzialità pensate che non è neanche
necessario io trovo un'impronta sulla
scena del crimine mi basta un frammento
lo posso inserire nella mia banca dati e
capire a chi appartiene
vedere questi studenti in piazza stanno
manifestando siamo a Reggio Calabria
l'anno del 2005 siamo indignati sono
indignati e protestano perché è stato
ucciso il via Locri il vicepresidente
del Consiglio regionale della Calabria
Francesco fortugno è stato ucciso da un
killer molto coperto con 5 colpi d'arma
da fuoco dentro Il seggio dove si
svolgevano le elezioni primarie del suo
partito
volete sapere come abbiamo fatto a
risalire agli esecutori materiali e ai
mandanti di quell'omicidio tutti i
condannati in Cassazione ci siamo
riusciti grazie al primo match
automatico della banca dati delle
indagini balistiche una banca dati che
contiene al suo interno tutte le
immagini di Boss del proiettili
riportati in varie scene del crimine e
le correla Tra loro In sostanza quella
bancatari ci ha detto che la pistola che
aveva ucciso fortugno era la stessa che
aveva sparato un anno prima a Locri
durante una festa di paese dove un tizio
per goliardia aver esploso dei colpi in
aria e questa chiamata la volante aveva
recuperato avevamo messo in banca dati a
quel punto è stato più semplice capire
chi aveva sparato alla festa e
attraverso l'arma risalire agli
assassini
noi su questa banca dati abbiamo
investito tantissimo pensate che oggi
sulla scena del crimine se non trovo un
proiettile non fa niente Mi basta una
scheggia anche quella può essere
inserita banca dati ed è utile per un
confronto perché oggi lavoriamo su dati
tridimensionali abbiamo più informazioni
ricordate la vicenda del papello il
famoso documento al centro della
trattativa tra lo Stato e la mafia per
noi era fondamentale capire se quel
documento fosse autentico
e per capirlo lo dovevamo datare avevamo
applicato ben 6 tecniche di indagini
merceologica ma ancora non ci eravamo
riusciti Alla fine per la prima volta in
un'indagine di quel tipo abbiamo dovuto
applicare la tecnica del carbonio 14 e
per farlo ci siamo dovuti fare aiutare
da un istituto di ricerca un ente
specializzato perché la strumentazione è
complicatissima e grande come una stanza
la potete vedere qui nelle immagini
oggi alla polizia scientifica abbiamo
imparato ad innovare non diciamo più se
è sempre fatto così oggi Diciamo cercare
di capire come lo possiamo fare meglio
questo è il nostro obiettivo
abbiamo imparato a fare ricerca o a
farla fare a chi è più bravo di noi
abbiamo imparato a cercare le migliori
tecnologie sul mercato e calarle nel
nostro ambito
oggi una metà del nostro personale
Lavora sui casi ordinari e l'altra metà
a far ricerca e interviene soltanto nei
casi più complessi tecnicamente più
importanti a livello nazionale
Vi potrei dire che le potremmo
considerare un po' le teste di cuoio
della scienza
non siamo più una struttura ferma Noi
siamo una struttura in movimento una
struttura che cammina che fa passi
avanti Ogni volta che facciamo un passo
avanti aumenta il nostro know ed entra a
far parte della nostra cultura
investigativa e questo fa prendere l'ago
della bilancia sempre più dalla parte
della giustizia ma non solo ogni volta
che facciamo un passo in avanti c'è un
altro vantaggio che è l'effetto sorpresa
ricordate quando sono usciti i primi
telefoni cellulari nessuno pensava
all'intercettazioni tanto che era molto
facile incastrare i delinquenti Beh oggi
non è più così è tutto più conosciuto
e poi ci sono i criminali incalliti
quelli che appartengono alla Lucrezio
alle organizzazioni mafiose al
terrorismo anche loro rinnovano E
comunque se non innovano seguono da
vicino i nostri progressi imparano a
lasciare le tracce
e poi c'è la spettacolarizzazione dei
processi al giorno d'oggi ci sono
giornali e televisioni che si alimentano
esclusivamente di cronaca nera e gli
piace mostrare tutte le tecniche
investigative
nel 2005
A Londra ci fu un attentato alla
metropolitana dove morirono 56 persone
dopo pochi giorni ce ne fu un altro che
fortunatamente fa lì Uno dei
responsabili venne arrestato proprio a
Roma il 4 settembre dalla polizia il
giorno successivo su tutti i giornali
c'era scritto in dettaglio come aveva
fatto la polizia scientifica a
localizzare Il latitante
per questo motivo noi dobbiamo sempre
dobbiamo essere sempre un passo avanti
non ci vestivamo fermare Dobbiamo
camminare ma dobbiamo anche camminare
velocemente infatti abbiamo messo
appunto delle nuove tecniche
Chiaramente oggi qui non ve le posso
raccontare lo capirete
Però una cosa ve la posso dire Tutti
hanno bisogno di innovare non solo le
aziende ai Tech che lo fanno per
mestiere ma anche piccole grandi e medie
imprese le pubbliche amministrazioni la
scuola i privati e Novara è difficile
però il messaggio che vi voglio dare
oggi è che la polizia scientifica ce
l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta anche se
appartiene alla pubblica amministrazione
una tra le più grandi una tra le più
complesse la nostra Pubblica
Amministrazione è gerarchica è gestita
con regole ferree la potremmo definire
militarizzata dove tutto è scritto nella
carta dove tutto è tramandato
Eppure ci siamo riusciti anche se è
difficile e comunque la cosa più
difficile di tutti è stata cambiare le
persone superare la mentalità le
abitudini e la cultura delle persone
questo è stato lo scoglio più grande da
superare
volete sapere come l'abbiamo fatto
ci siamo riusciti Perché alcuni dei
nostri migliori investigatori e tecnici
forensi hanno fatto carriera hanno
vissuto delle esperienze come la mia
sono arrivati a contatto con i vertici
della nostra amministrazione Alcuni di
loro sono diventati essi stessi vertici
e hanno trasmesso la cultura del
cambiamento e l'esigenza
dell'Innovazione e da quel momento ci
hanno rimosso gli ostacoli
È stata dura perché abbiamo dovuto
riprogrammare gli uffici ristrutturarci
cambiare la nostra organizzazione
gerarchica cambiare tutto la struttura
Ma la cosa veramente importante è con
chi l'abbiamo fatto questo cambiamento
l'abbiamo fatto arruolando tutta una
serie di giovani motivati e preparati
gli abbiamo dato fiducia e
responsabilità e loro ci hanno ripagato
e da quel momento Abbiamo ricominciato a
correre
voglio dire che se anche tutte le
amministrazioni pubbliche e private
facessero la stessa cosa secondo me
tutto il paese potrebbe rimettersi a
correre
voglio concludere dicendovi perché lo
abbiamo fatto proprio noi perché
comunque noi siamo la Polizia e quando
lavoriamo ad un caso abbiamo sempre
nelle mani la sicurezza anzi diciamo la
vita delle persone
dedico questo Talk al piccolo Tommy